foreign
August 2022 and it's been a year since
the emergency evacuations from
Afghanistan after it fell to the Taliban
fifteen thousand people were evacuated
from Kabul Airport to the UK in just two
weeks of operation pitting I'm Sky News
Chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey and at
the time we reported on those chaotic
flights to Safety in this podcast out of
Afghanistan we're asking what happened
next what happened to those suddenly
starting life over on the other side of
the world it is not easy to make good
friends in a different places like UK we
didn't have anyone and we were really
around I didn't think she would say let
us meet there because some people they
don't give you her time in the previous
episodes we heard about the support
available to Afghans here in the UK
through shabano a mother who struggled
to get her daughter malali and nephew to
safety through Kabul Airport they now
live in Bristol reunited with a husband
Yusuf
we also met afsal and his wife they were
expecting their fourth child when they
had to leave Afghanistan their baby
daughter was born safely in Britain the
family of six was still living in a
hotel but now they have a Home of Their
Own
in this episode we're finding out about
integration how do you make friends in a
new place with a different language
different culture and different social
structures and what makes it easier for
some to settle but harder for others
last time we were in Bristol a busy
diverse City but when the home office
asked local authorities across the UK to
offer accommodation it meant some
families were placed in more remote
parts of the country when we came to
peterhead there was not any Afghan
families here just three Afghan families
come together here one other Afghan
families also come about two months ago
and two single boy also as I heard I
didn't meet them yet at lunchtime
we got the chicken giant chicken
Ali had been an interpreter for American
and British troops and was amongst the
first to be relocated to safety through
the government's Afghanistan relocations
and assistance policy or Arab scheme he
was evacuated along with his wife
Carmella and seven-year-old son Naveed
the family living in a two-bedroom flat
close to Naveed School in peterhead a
bus service connects them to Aberdeen
their closest big city but it's 30 miles
South it's a long expensive journey
peterhead is famous for its fishing port
sitting on the Easter most point of the
Scottish mainland
and your arrivals from Afghanistan were
in for a shock I was no any idea about
peterhead what kind of people and what
kind of location is there after not very
long time the weather changed it too
much and winter was too cold and we
couldn't go out all the winter we feel
like an isolation and current in here in
our house yeah we couldn't go outside
because they are too rainy and weather
all the time 24 hours heater was on it
was expensive
I care from falling debris things like
trees there was one really bad storm in
this winter many many trees fall down
now on that time it is really difficult
for every family not just for me
I was lucky I had my electricity and I
had my gas but most of the people who is
living around me and peterhead and other
aberdeenshire the electricity cut off
yeah for a long time
actually it is a challenge but we can't
change the challenge to the
opportunities it is not a problem to not
be safe like an Afghan like Afghanistan
it is good I'm happy at least I have my
wife my child here and at least I'm
alive right now it's good in Afghanistan
the family live with their many
relatives Aunts Uncles and cousins
plenty of other children for Naveed to
play with
so it's been an adjustment living alone
as a family of three
they're trying to find a sense of
community here
Ali says Regional groups and businesses
in the area organized a far warmer
welcome than the harsh winter weather
provided after one big Community
invite us to Aberdeen City and they
organized an event for welcoming Afghan
people to Scotland it was really nice
for me I understand these people as
really respectful and they respect me as
well on that time they asked me to speak
about the situation in Afghanistan I've
spoken with them and actually some of
them cried for Afghan people I
understand how much humanity and
tolerance is here in the UK and British
people
another time they invite me in a match
in football club and they invite us for
a lunch as well and the Christmas time a
student of that Ellen Academy sent for
me like 100 card Merry Christmas Ali and
your family we wish you happiness in
Scotland you know this all come together
and make me very happy and motivated for
my future I had to communicate with his
new community another challenge a
fundamental one this is really a hard to
chat and speak with the local people
here they are asking this completely
different speaking English wasn't the
issue as an interpreter Ali already
knows the language he's found a
different Regional accent difficult to
understand some of the sentence I don't
understand I don't catch them especially
when they are speaking with each other
they use some different words that I
have never heard they use different
accent and they are speaking to fast as
well but I'm trying my best to fit
myself with them I'm asking them once
again please or pardon me they are very
kind and speak again and slowly when
they understand me that uh this is my
second language there is a lot of
different for example I'm telling
British they are telling British they
they change T to a for example they are
not telling water they are telling
it is different with with England and
they are telling if you are not English
pure Scottish and they don't tell me
Scottish they are telling they are SRS
yet
Ali's wife Camilla is learning English
and so is a seven-year-old Naveed
when my son gone to school for the first
time actually I was wondering how is it
possible for him because he didn't
understand his teacher his teacher
didn't understand his language he didn't
understand his classmate he had no
English even alphabet
first week I was very worried about him
it was really nice after 10 days one
amount sometimes he was speaking some
English words I was happy then his
teacher also contact me early in a
video's progress very very good and one
day he sent a certificate that nabid can
speak very well English right now yeah I
know children is really good for picking
up different language it is like eight
months or nine months that he is going
to school he can speak English better
than me
it's so cold
it is not like the best bathroom
warm water it's not bathroom I know not
bathroom it is Beach
it's good water
[Music]
how are we this morning
yeah how are you this morning
good morning are you good good
I'm Dr Valeria Hennessy and I own
International House Bristol where we
teach English as a foreign language
back in Bristol many of the refugees who
had taken up English courses on offer
are coming here to study and take exams
not only to interact with others in
their daily life but also to help them
find jobs I think language skills are
the
Bridge with the people in the post
office in the shop in the supermarket in
the doctor's surgery if you're
constantly depending on your children to
translate for you which a lot of these
people are it diminishes you as a person
as an adult as a parent it takes away
your dignity and yes it's great that
they've been given a place of safety but
they need human dignity as well they're
offered language courses for various
levels of ability the ones we see are
adults children obviously go into local
schools and children learn extremely
quickly if they're prepubescent anyway
so you don't need to do anything special
with them they'll pick up language like
sponges for their parents it's much more
difficult and these people have lost
everything including their sense of
social identity and the respect of
earning their own living and that's very
difficult to take and sometimes they
come with amazing skills but they can't
make use of them last year I had a
dentist from Syria who just wants to be
a dentist again or short of dentists but
he can't get his English to the right
level learning the language helps
refugees to integrate but best way to
learn is of course by interacting with
others which isn't easy when you feel
like an outsider and we all know that
the older you get the more difficult it
is to learn something new and with
language you do need to be practicing
you need to be comfortable you need to
feel that it's okay to make mistakes and
for many of them they live in very
isolated
ways within Bristol they've been welcome
to Bristol and Bristol city council have
been amazing they're funding this
particular course
but these people need more access to the
rest of the city they need to be using
their English on a daily basis they need
to be practicing with native speakers
and there's a certain amount of
trepidation on their side I think that
they feel they won't be understood
yes
we had an engineer last year and he was
from Syria and he was absolutely
desperate to get back into engineering
but he also was a single father of four
children and he didn't have the language
skills so if there are opportunities out
there for people like him he's not going
to see them he's not going to recognize
the opportunities there and I think
what's missing is a lot of joined up
thinking because there are people
helping these refugees but employers
need to be looking at them as well
because you can very quickly take a
refugee who has basic language skills
and by giving them work by letting them
interact with other people those
language skills will improve even in an
adult
foreign
but what is the measure of success when
it comes to integration
Jennifer is a professor of migration and
super diversity at the University of
birmingham's Iris Center there is not
one definition of what successful
integration is governments tend to view
successful integration as reaching a
similar sort of level in terms of
educational employment housing and
health outcomes as the general
population
academics have got a much broader
understanding and they would be thinking
about parity of participation so being
able to have all the rights and
entitlements feeling at home being
welcomed and indeed the population as a
whole adapting to take into account
its changing diversity as different
migrant populations arrive but some have
an advantage children are primary school
level just fit in so quickly you know
they adapt very fast they pick up the
language and they do so well in
education it's harder for teenagers
because you know particularly if they've
been out of school for a while which is
the case for some refugees you know in
the past we've had young men arrive from
Somalia who basically have been excluded
from education their whole lives and
then they're slotted into a you know a
class with other 15 year olds unable to
even write in their own language so
obviously that presents a lot of
difficulties those people who are higher
educated and who already speak a bit of
the local language also do very very
well but you know we see that people are
able to adapt as long as they're given
the right levels of support and and
welcome
it's not always this straightforward
though especially for malali
when we first met her and her father she
just turned 10. she's found it really
hard to fit in at her new Primary School
but Dad Youssef wants her to persevere
and
you in here
and he goes to school but I don't have
any friends because I can't speak so
much English in Afghanistan I have so
much friends and I miss it so much I
hate break time oh just boring time and
and break time and then I like to study
in
when I come here then the schools are so
much different because in Afghanistan in
fourth class we have 12 books to learn
12 books and in here we we have no books
no homework no nothing just playing
and Afghanistan we have no breakdown
like break time we have it only 15
minutes and no lunch time
we've just bring it our lunch from our
home and eat it in this 15 minutes
it's so easy in here so much easy but
just the problem is I I can't speak so
much English
yeah only no friends yeah no friends
you'll find friends because you're new
here
like they already have their friends
they don't need anymore
because they've been together for five
years
in your join them just now so it will
take you some time to make friends and
if you go to high school secondary
school so then you will find because all
the girls will be new to that school
from around other schools then you can
easily find them
work and school are good places to meet
and make friends over time but some
refugees do not have either it's harder
for them
to say in the film can't capture the
smell the locations of the bridging
hotels in Bristol haven't been
publicized partly for privacy so others
can't just drop in instead some
organizations are holding events like
walks peace feasts craft or sporting
events to help bristolians and Afghans
connect I'm Dan Green and I'm the
managing director of a bristol-based
charity called bridges for communities
the council has given us access to the
the hotels and we've gone in and done
welcome events and we've also invited
people out
and part of our job has been to just try
and connect people in to the Goodwill of
the city but Dan says uncertainty
surrounding their future can be
discouraging for the refugees one of the
big challenges has been that people
don't know if they would stay in Bristol
so they've been living in this kind of
temporary life in hotel rooms some of
them wanting to be in Bristol others
wanting to be elsewhere and of course
everybody kind of with an eye on what's
Happening back home in Afghanistan as
well so it's been a I think a very
challenging time for all of those
families
integration is a two-way process so it
is not just about newcomers adapting and
adjusting to the British way of life
however we see that but it's about
people in host communities like myself
also learning listening and adjusting
and that way we get the benefit and the
enjoyment of learning to live well
together
but there is an adjustment process no
doubt and a lot of it is just about
becoming more familiar when things are
done different and one of the things we
say is what's normal for you is not
necessarily what's normal for everyone
else and that can be around
communication style but it could also be
around social norms very visible things
like dress code Etc and while language
and employment are advantages he says
other factors are also at play there is
this kind of cultural adjustment process
but it really varies from Individual to
individual and the factors that
determine if somebody settles in quick
quickly if someone starts to thrive more
quickly than others are very varied and
multi-layered there's also what else is
going on in your life
um you know the background of trauma the
background of what is currently
happening with loved ones and family in
other countries also plays a major role
and then attitude is another one and
that would be true if I was moving
overseas as well whether I want to adapt
for people who are moving because of war
or any kind of force displacement that
attitude of wanting to fit in rebuild
your life have a new sense of identity
and belonging
is one that very naturally would take a
longer time
so I think we need to have a lot of
patience with people because there's so
much going on
in peterhead Ali and his family are on
their way back from a weekend trip to
the beach
they've spent time alongside other
families swimming paddling and sailing
this is job sector for us many times I
come here for appointment you know
anyone who can newly should have
appointment many times in job center and
right now you know since I I'm going to
my work I'm not coming here and all my
appointments finished now
after a long search Alice found a job
working for a construction company and
he is thrilled he can't drive in the UK
yet so a colleague picks him up and
drops him off every day
they're long days at work and Ali spends
most evenings processing paperwork to
move his family's lives forward
he's now passed his driving Theory test
and as a date for his practical he needs
to change his automatic license from
Afghanistan into a manual one
he's also working to get his Afghan
educational qualifications formally
recognized here
which will help with work and with his
goal to study for a master's degree in
the future yeah the next Junction you
can turn left
Ali's Mantra to turn challenges into
opportunities is admirable but that
doesn't always mean it's been easy he
still finds it hard to establish
meaningful friendships it is not easy to
make good friends and at different
places like UK my colleague all all of
them is friendly with me and I'm
friendly with them as well and if I go
to any Community to have a chat with
them then I can make friendly with them
but if do not be any Community any
organization to chat or any
opportunities to speak with the people
it is impossible to make a friend the
Afghan families also like to spend time
together and help each other out during
the peak yeah we are busy I'm going to
my job and my friends also going to
their work and at the weekend sometimes
we are going come together in one house
and playing card with other Afghan
family refugees and sometimes you are
going to the beach sometimes we are
going to walking running jogging yeah
and sometimes we come together if we
Face any problem peterhead has plenty of
shops nice beaches a Health Center job
center and Council offices and a
football club
but it lacks some of the things that are
important to families who are practicing
Muslims unfortunately if you are not
close to Aberdeen City it is about 45 15
minutes drive from our house to go for
Halal shop to go to the mosque to
practice our religious as Afghan or
hundred percent Muslim and they are
really important for them to access to
the mosque and practice their religious
yeah and to see other Muslim people over
there if we go to the bus we have to
spend eight pounds for each way that
becomes 16 pounds it is not it is too
expensive for for a new life actually
anyone who have no job from here with
the bus we have to go for one hour one
hour more we have to buy our our staff
then one hour we should come back at
least take three hours so it is it is
chilling a challenge for for all African
families who are living in peterhead
they all want to move actually all all
Afghan families who are living in in
peterhead they applied and all looking
for for going to about density to the
big city Yes actually I want to move
from Peter ahead the weather is too cold
and I have to be in the big city I think
I could manage more to go grow up my
life
people contact me directly as well as an
Afghan myself my phone would ring and
somebody would say I'm in the Isle of
Skye or I'm further up people are in all
places in Dundee in in Brewery yeah
there's one family in stone away so I
don't know if how far they could go than
that severe says a is chief executive of
the Scottish Refugee Council based in
Glasgow he himself fled Afghanistan in
1999 and came to the UK as an asylum
Seeker he says refugees can still live
well outside of the bigger cities my
message to people who have been
resettled always is that um
you don't need to be living next door to
a mosque or to your cultural facilities
to be part of that Community it's
important that people feel that sense of
ownership and belonging to their local
areas you might not be living next to
daughter and Afghan your neighbor may
not cook the same food or may not sound
like you they could still be a good
neighbor and I think the same is the
message to people who will have an
Afghan next door to them and the only
Afghan in their town and Village and
they may not go to the pub with you or
to the church with you they could still
be a very good neighbor the good thing
is that all these Afghan families are
coming with a lot of skills and
potential the SRC links Afghan refugees
in Scotland through WhatsApp groups it
encourages them to stay in touch with
each other and keep on top of events
they're invited to and of course job
opportunities
Sevilla says it's important to be
open-minded about the future wherever
they find themselves this is not
Afghanistan where all of the prosperity
is in the capital or in bigger cities
but if you have Ambitions if you have
your skills and talents you can start
off anywhere as long as you have shelter
as long as you have a dignified income
and you play an active role no matter
where you are you're part of that
Society
despite the earlier struggles fitting
into a new school in Bristol
ten-year-old malali says things are
getting easier now I have two friends in
my school
two girls one from your Romania and one
from Iraq Kurdistan yeah yeah they born
here they're in year five and I'm in
nearby either but we're not the same
class so how did you meet them then in
the playground yeah
she's chatting with Chris a woman her
mother shabano met through a shared love
of sewing Chris is a quilting expert and
lives with her husband Neil the women
are planning new sewing projects
together and the two families now meet
at each other's homes regularly
right so
this is my sewing room isn't it yeah
yeah
my sewing machine and um lots of fabric
here
like when she is making a dress or
anything so she have to cut it and then
she cut it here
on the table
yeah I'll do it on here well I was
involved in setting up a project
teaching Afghani ladies to quilt so I
was introduced to shirbano and I said
well please come to my group and I do
this on a Friday and it would just help
me so much if you could translate for me
and we just started our friendship like
that and we know it's going to last
forever
yeah when I first met Christina and she
we just changed our phone numbers and
then she come to my home just for a
green tea Afghani green tea and after
that after a week we come to here to her
house and she made a nice cake for us I
made a rice yeah yeah it was the second
time yeah that was the second time first
time we just come and see the house
everything in malali was very happy and
I thought Chris will be my friend but
she's now malali is more friends
this is cold
a lemon drizzle cake wow I like it good
that's why I made it because you liked
it last time
the smell is so good
yeah
malali loves the outdoor space at Chris
and Neil's house the big trees and the
wild mint growing in the garden Neil
Cuts them in to give it to malali's
Father Yusuf we didn't have anyone and
we were really around I didn't think she
would have said it is meat there because
some people they don't give you her time
even we feel like a mom and her husband
nil like her she said yeah like Penance
both of us have traveled a lot and and
um I can't imagine how you must have
felt leaving your home and and coming
here and uh you know because it's hard
you know my husband feels the same way
you know this is part of our family now
foreign
those who've shared their stories with
us are moving forward with their lives
under the resettlement schemes but the
move and separation from loved ones has
not been easy
each family that traveled to the UK has
their own story
you've heard some of them but we met
others some who couldn't risk taking
their young children to Kabul Airport
children they've now been separated from
for months
others told us about their family back
in Afghanistan who are in hiding and
moving frequently they live in fear of
the Taliban
Afghanistan's failing economy means many
there are without jobs and food
these are stories they may be able to
share with us and with you on this
podcast in the future
their lives may be moving forward in the
UK but their stories and that of
Afghanistan are far from over
[Music]
out of Afghanistan was presented by me
Stuart Ramsey and produced by Anne-Marie
Bullock sound design was by Will chalk
Paul stanworth is the editor
foreign